is still incredibly high and now the
cost of filling up an average family
sized car is going to cost you a hundred
pounds pretty grim for some of the
drivers i spoke to today
the price when you go to petrol station
is shocking so you paid hundreds and
seventy some pages and then it saves you
197.
you don't calculate straight away
overall what the final figure will be
and it's shocking you're thinking
that's more than 10 that increase within
a week for me to drop my wife to the
school and come
and if i do it five times a week
that's 100 pound gone you know oh it's
it's horrible because before you could
fill up your tank for like 50 pounds
like you say it's doubling um petrol
prices even at this petrol station are
rising by 10 p every five days so it's
quite a shock so i think it will hit two
pounds by the weekend
the trajectory is simply going in the
wrong direction emma it's simply going
up and for many people like the ones i
spoke to there today it's simply not
sustainable for them the ra c have said
this is a deeply depressing threshold
that has now been passed they are saying
that that fuel duty that cut to fuel
duty that the government brought in in
march needs to go further they've called
for a temporary reduction in vat the
governments say this is to do with what
they brought in in march this cut to
fuel duty by five feet per liter they
are saying that some retailers haven't
translated that discount to here on the
forecourts and it's therefore not
reaching consumers in the way that it
should be in response to that the petrol
retailers association has said that
they're not profiting from
this at these rising prices in fact many
of them are selling petrol for much
lower than what it's meant to be sold at
so we're making a loss now motoring
bodies will say that the government
needs to do a lot more and very quickly
to try and rein in that those excesses
but ultimately that's going to be little
comfort to motorists who are filling up
here today when they're filling up their
cars looking at their receipts and
sometimes seeing three figures
okay ashna thank you
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest sky news daily podcast with fuel
prices hitting another record high
vanessa buffo explores what's behind the
rising cost of living talking at the
cost of living is the prime minister
boris johnson this afternoon and very
very good to to to be here in blackpool
and the final college
um
after 70 years of an astonishing reign i
think there are many reasons why queen
elizabeth will be remembered as one of
our very greatest monarchs but there's
one particular criterion that's applied
to all reigns throughout history what
happened to
the people what the condition of the
people
and in the last 70 years the british
people have begun to live lives that
were unimaginable even to our
grandparents that's even our parents to
travel the world to communicate to
express ourselves artistically
politically culturally as never before
we are at the forefront of multiple
waves of scientific and technical
advance we live longer
healthier
and more prosperous lives than any
previous generation
as we look back at that enormous span of
history our monarch's lifetime we see
that this progress was sometimes uneven
and sometimes achieved against serious
headwinds an existential war when the
very independence of our country was
threatened the suez crisis industrial
disputes that tore communities apart
riots stagflation the persistent scourge
of high unemployment
today
we're living in the aftermath of the
worst pandemic for a century and once
again we are steering into the wind
we face global pressures on prices
caused by the lingering effects of covid
and the shock of putin's aggression in
ukraine we'll get through it
we'll get through it just as we got
through the far greater challenge of
covid and the colossal fall in output
that entailed
our position is far better than during
past economic difficulties people don't
face the misery of the 1980s or 1990s of
being told in their millions that they
were surplus to requirements there was
no job that they could do
we now have unemployment at its lowest
level since 1974
and youth unemployment at or near a
record low
it's an amazing fact that we now have
more job vacancies than there are
unemployed workers to fill them
and that in itself is feeding
inflationary
pressures i want to talk frankly about
what we need to do together so that we
come through this period together as
fast and as strongly as possible
and the first step is to understand the
scale and the causes of the problem
everyone can see and feel the impact on
household budgets the increases in the
cost of food the spooling digits on the
petrol pumps energy bills growing
seemingly ever larger
much of this has been driven by problems
in global supply chains that followed
the pandemic the sudden surge in demand
for gas from china the world shortage of
container ships six months ago there
were good reasons
to hope that the laws of supply and
demand would start to operate and these
problems would
would begin to abandon the world
responded for instance to the shortage
of lorry drivers by hiring more paying
them better and giving them more better
conditions
that progress was brutally interrupted
on the 24th of february when putin
decided on his disastrous and unprovoked
war in ukraine
world markets have responded with a
significant
spike in prices partly driven by
sanctions partly by the elevated risk
premium the inevitable increase in what
businesses have to charge to compensate
for raised global levels of uncertainty
the price of oil and gas looks likely to
remain high for a while to come and the
same goes for grain and feed and
fertilizer
and i know there are some who may argue
not in this country uh perhaps but but
elsewhere
that the price of supporting the
ukrainians is now too high and they
should be encouraged to accept whatever
terms putin may ask
i don't believe that option is really
open to us
never mind that abandoning the
ukrainians would be morally repugnant
since they are the victims
and they have an absolute right to
defend a free and independent country
we are simply not in a position to tell
them what to do
they have shown by their heroism that
they will fight to defend their homeland
and they they have shown that they will
win
putin has made a colossal strategic
error he's fundamentally misunderstood
the psychology of his opponents and what
ukraine really is
he will never succeed in subduing
ukraine and the sooner he comes
to that understanding the better
but nor should he be allowed the partial
success
of swallowing some of the country as he
has done before and declaring a
ceasefire
he would be able to continue to twist
the knife in the wound the crocodile
would simply come back for more and he
would be able to claim that his
aggression and his violence had paid off
that would be a disaster
for ukraine and all the other parts of
the former soviet union that he might
attack and perhaps even for countries
one thing's in poland uh beyond former
soviet boundaries disaster for them
to encourage a bad peace in ukraine is
to encourage putin and to encourage all
those around the world who believe that
aggression pays and that would be
a mistake that would open the door to
further conflict
further instability
further
global uncertainty and therefore further
economic misery
i say this
because i do not believe there is a
quick fix in ukraine and because we must
continue to support the ukrainians as we
have from the beginning for as long as
it takes but over time i believe the
economic consequences of the war in
ukraine will abate
the europeans and others who depend on
russian hydrocarbons and whis by the way
we still get 15 of our diesel uh from
russia but we'll fight we it was thirty
percent there's 950 we'll find other
sources
the whole tragic experience will greatly
accelerate the rush to clean low carbon
energy of all kinds and over time the
inflationary effects will start to
diminish we're dealing
with labor market shortages not just by
reaching for the old lever of
uncontrolled mass immigration but with a
points-based system that gives us the
workforce we need
we're solving it by getting people by
the way off welfare into work 380 000
now have gone off welfare into work
under the way to work scheme above all
by skilling up british people uh with
the lifetime skills guarantee and all
the investments that this government is
proud to make in uh into fantastic uh
colleges such as the one i'm proud to be
standing in today
we're trying to fix the labor market in
addition to everything else but we must
deal with the here and now as it affects
families in our country we've got to
recognize the pressures on household
budgets that for some will be simply
unaffordable
especially as the energy price cap goes
up
in the autumn
so this government
is on the side of the british public in
coping with those pressures
as the chancellor has announced we are
directly helping the most vulnerable 8
million households with cash payments
worth 1200 pounds every household in the
country will get 400 pounds towards
their energy costs most will get a 150
pound council tax rebate pensioners in
receipt of winter fuel payments will get
another 300 pounds and the disabled will
get another 150 pounds
taken together with the funds already
committed that is 37 billion pounds to
help with the cost of living
we have the fiscal firepower to help and
we will
we will back britain
and we will back the british people for
as long as it takes
but of course there's only one reason
why we can currently afford to make
these enormous commitments
and that is because we responded to the
pandemic with a series of difficult but
ultimately responsible decisions
first we protected families and
businesses with a package of support
worth about 400 billion pounds that was
among the most generous in the world
then having rolled out vaccines faster
than any other european country we were
able to open up our economy faster
and that's why we've had such a rapid
rebound in employment and last year with
the fastest growing g7 economy and it's
that fundamental strength that the tax
base of a high wage high skill low
unemployment economy that enables us to
look after the british people that's how
we can afford to cover the costs
and we will continue to do what we can
for as long as it takes
that was the pledge that i made to you
to the british public during coved are
we delivered and we will deliver again
at the same time we must face some
realities
the first is that no government in the
world can afford to use taxpayers money
to shield everyone completely from the
increased costs caused by powerful
global forces
when we protected the population during
covid the package of help was massively
progressive in the sense that it went
overwhelmingly to the most vulnerable
households and we'll do the same in the
aftershocks of kobe we'll get the right
balance between spending what we can
afford now and making sure there is a
healthy economy to look forward to when
the pressures abate
and while some support is of course
going to be universal the bulk of it
will be targeted at those who need it
most and i think that approach is right
and supported by the vast majority of
people in this country
the second reality
is that when you face inflationary
pressure
you can't just spend your way out of it
on the contrary you have to be careful
not to add to inflationary pressure we
are constrained in what we can do not
just by the fiscal position
the risk of borrowing too much
but by the risk that we will fan the
flames of further price increases
which brings us to the third reality
that we can't
fix the increase in the cost of living
just by increasing wages to match the
surge in prices i i think it's naturally
a good thing for wages to go up
skills and productivity increase that's
what we want to see and so we've been
increasing wages with a record increase
in the living wage changes to universal
credit
but when a country faces an inflationary
problem you can't just pay more and
spend more
you have to find ways of tackling the
underlying causes of inflation if wages
continually chase the increase in prices
then we risk a wage price spiral such as
this country experienced in
the 1970s you know far too young from
the 1970s i do
stagflation and that is inflation
combined with stagnant economic growth
when a wage price spiral begins there is
only one cure and that is to slam the
brakes on
rising prices with higher interest rates
and that has an immediate impact on
mortgages on rents
it puts up the cost of borrowing for
business it's bad for investment and
growth it's bad for jobs it's bad for
everyone and of course the in the
increase in interest rates
it can considerably increases the cost
of borrowing for government we're
already spending 83 billion pounds this
year alone in servicing our debts and
every extra percentage point in interest
payments is another 21 billion pounds
that has to go on paying lenders for our
borrowing that's money that will have to
be paid back by our children and
grandchildren it's money that could go
on schools and hospitals
so we have the tools we need to get on
top of rising prices the the global
headwinds are strong but our
engines the great super charge ultra
green marine propulsion units of the uh
uk economy are stronger we will we will
get through it
and while it's not going to be quick or
easy you can be confident that things
will get better and that we will emerge
from this economy uh much from this with
a strong
country with a strong and healthy
economy
that won't happen if we continue to to
apply the same mindset that we had
during coven that is the answer to every
problem is more state spending
we're already engaged in the biggest
package of infrastructure investment for
more than a century we're transforming
our railways our roads we're investing
massively in skills
in research we're making our communities
safer 13 576 police already out on the
streets of the twenty thousand that we
promised helping to bring neighborhood
crime down already uh by thirty one
percent we're tackling the the coveted
backlogs hiring thousands and more
doctors and nurses to speed up
treatments uh we're opening community
diagnostic hubs across this country so
you can get the test or the scan that
you need but faster we're fixing social
care
so that we can end delayed discharges
far too many hospital beds are occupied
by patients who could be better cared
for elsewhere were investing in
education huge sums in defense in in the
whole agenda that this government was
elected to deliver to unite and level up
across our country and we're keeping the
promises we're keeping the promises that
will make a difference to millions of
lives over the next decade and long long
into the future
it costs money
prodigious sums
and the result is that the overall
burden of taxation is now very high
and sooner or later and i would much
rather it was sooner than later
that burden must come down
it's an aberration the burden of tax
caused in no small part by the fiscal
meteorite of kovid and it must come down
because the answer to the current
economic predicament is not more tax and
more spending
the answer is economic growth and you
can't spend your way out of inflation
and you can't tax your way
into growth
so that's why the time has come for this
government to do uh what it's been
straining at the leash to do for two
years but which has been difficult
during the kobe crisis and that is to
enact the supply side reforms that will
cut the costs of government
cut costs for business and cut costs for
people across the country
let me take them in that order it cannot
be right that the size of central
government has increased by 23
since 2015. there are 91 000 more
officials than there were i believe we
have the best civil service in the world
but in view of the pressure now on
families we've got to find efficiencies
prune back whitehall to the size it was
only five or six years ago i think
that's something we can achieve without
harming the public services they deliver
and in expanding and encouraging the
private sector it's time for the
government to stop spending and to start
cutting taxes and cutting regulation
this has been an era of phenomenal
corporate welfare
from ppe contracts that were driven by
the desperation of the pandemic to
billions of pounds invested driven by
the same desperation in vaccines and
antivirals
to the whole array of businesses that
were quite rightly supported by the
furlough bounce back loans sea bills all
those other programs
of course this government is going to
continue to invest in the bedrock of the
economy on which businesses build their
foundations infrastructure skills
technology
but sometimes
the best way the government can help
is simply to get out of the way
to do less or to do it better or simply
and not at all if governments have
billions the markets have trillions and
we need to see more of that investment
by businesses here in the uk
that's why we're not taking advantage of
brexit freedoms accelerating reform of
solvency to a one-size-fits-all eu
dictat which has been unnecessarily
preventing insurance and pension funds
and others from making giant investments
in uk firms and and in infrastructure
we've put a super deduction of 130
on capital investment giving uk firms an
unparalleled opportunity to invest we're
opening free ports around the country
with low tax arrangements and special
planning regimes to enable growth and
investment
we can turbo charge the city by
rewriting and improving eu regulations
such as method two
now we need to go further and we will
identifying all the ways in which
government rules and regulations are
pushing up costs for business and
increasing prices for everyone in this
country
over the next few weeks this government
will be setting out reforms to help
people cut costs in every area of
household expenditure from food to
energy to child care to transport and
housing and we will do this despite any
complaints that there may be from those
with vested interest because this
government is firmly on your side in
cutting those costs we're on the side
for instance with of british farmers
we need to grow
more and eat more of our own food in
this country and i think it's sensible
to protect british agriculture from cut
price or substandard food from overseas
but we're also on the side of british
consumers
we do not grow many olives in this
country that i'm aware of why do we have
a tariff of 93 per kilo on turkish
olives turkish olive oil
why do we have a tariff on bananas this
is a truly amazing and versatile country
but as far as i know we do not grow many
bananas but not even in blackpool
we we are on your side
we are on your side in tackling fuel
bills and not just with the cash help
that i've set out just now
we have cut fuel duty already cut fuel
gt by record amount and what we want to
see is those businesses passing on
those savings
to consumers uh whether it's at the
pumps or supermarkets or anywhere else
and i know many businesses many
businesses some are taking price but i
know many businesses can see the wisdom
of protecting their customers rather
than simply taking profits now
one of the ways of course to reduce
energy costs is to increase energy
supply
and that's why the british energy
security strategy is going for a step
change in the quantity of wind power we
generate 50 gigawatts by 2030 returning
the uk uh to the status of the number
one wind power producer in uh offshore
windpower producer in the world
we are undoing the mistakes of many
previous governments and building a new
nuclear reactor every year rather than
one every 10 years along with many other
reforms and over the next few years this
will have a dramatic effect on the uk's
power output one that will be immensely
beneficial for consumers and businesses
alike
we are on your side in cutting the costs
of transport not just with the fantastic
investments that we're making it's time
for us to grasp the nettle of reform
and move sensibly and responsibly to the
end of some outdated working practices
there are fully manned ticket offices in
this country that barely sell a ticket a
week
and now 10 years ago as chairman of
transport for london i moved to take
advantage of new ticket offices by
closing uh ticket offices on the uh on
the underground
it was initially painful and the union
chiefs predict predicted catastrophe but
we successfully made the argument that
staff were better and more productively
deployed on the platforms interacting
with the public and the time has come to
do the same thing across the transport
network
the union barons will uh protest
but the winners the winners will be
railway staff whose industry will be
placed on a much sounder long-term
footing and the fair paying public and
we're on your side by the way and
cutting the cost of child care about
which i speak feelingly we're making it
easier uh to be a child minder and
making sure parents make the most of
their tax free child care allowances
that already exist but aren't taken up
all these costs and more we will address
in the coming weeks but today i want to
talk about the single biggest chunk of
household expenditure and that is the
cost of housing itself
just this year alone the price of a home
in the uk has soared by an average of
9.8 percent uh to
278 000 pounds which is
24 000 pounds higher than this time last
year
and in 2021 prices rose faster than
wages
so that if you're one of the millions
and millions of people outside the
housing market and you're looking in for
every week and month that goes by the
dream of home ownership recedes further
into the distance and the average age of
first-time buyers has been rising
continuously the proportion of young
people who can afford to buy their own
home has been falling between 2005 and
2016 the proportion of 25 to 34 year
olds who owned their own home fell by 20
whereas in almost every other european
country that proportions actually been
rising
it's true that we still have higher
rates of overall homeownership just
ahead of france and just ahead
of germany uh ahead of those two
companies
and it's true that we're building more
as fast as we can after a sustained
decline in in homeownership rates under
the labor government that rate is now
starting to uh to go back up thanks to
our support for first-time buyers and
also because we're building more homes
last year there were 400 000
first-time buyers of property which was
a 20-year high but those raw numbers
disguise the fact that home ownership
is overwhelmingly concentrated amongst
the over 65s those who are able to buy
in an era when housing was much cheaper
if you look at the millennial generation
i can see some millennials here
just 31 percent can own their own homes
in the uk in france that figure is 41
now partly this is a function of supply
when labour left office of course they
famously remarked that there was no
money left they'd also totally failed to
build new homes at the rate that was
necessary and we've been sorting that
out ever since thanks to the planning
reforms that we've been putting in over
the last decade household house building
rates as i say uh reached at a 20-year
high uh but
everywhere else uh though outside london
i should clarify this outside london
where uh the present mayor is not
showing quite the speed and scale
achieved by his immediate uh predecessor
uh but despite the progress everywhere
outside london we remain one of the
slowest least prolific home building
countries amongst the 28 members of the
oecd
since 1970 france has built 16.7 million
homes whereas we have built just 8.9
million and in that period our
population has grown by more than 12
million people and and it's not true
that there isn't the place the space to
uh there aren't the sites where we can
uh build these homes there are fantastic
brownfield sites up and down this
country there are places where we can
build so that's why michael gove has
been developing plans to work hand in
hand with local communities across
england to build more of the right homes
in the right places we're going to put
more publicly owned brownfield land to
use to and seek to unlock the small
sites that are ideal for the kind of
unobtrusive development that communities
welcome with a priority for first-time
buyers and key workers we're supporting
self-built and custom-built homes as has
long been proposed by my colleague
richard bacon and we will sensitively
make use of existing planning rights for
example by making it easier to turn
disused agricultural buildings
into homes for local first-time buyers
and to support support farmers in
growing and diversifying their
businesses but it's not enough just to
build more homes we also need to
recognize
that while
the overwhelming majority of people want
the chance to buy their own home for far
too many
this finance required simply isn't
available
the challenge facing first-time buyers
today is bigger than anything we've seen
before
in in 20 20 years ago 2002 a home on
average cost four and a half times your
income
today
that multiple has risen to nine times
your income we have a ludicrous
situation
where plenty of younger people could
afford
payments their
bills but the ever spamming price of a
house or a flat has so inflated deposit
requirements that saving even just 10
is a wholly unrealistic proposition for
them
first time buyers are trying to hit a
continually moving target
and of course the global rise in the
cost of living is only
making life harder for those savers so
we want to make it easier to get a
mortgage
working with lenders so that they
recognize the credit worthiness of
tenants with a track record of paying
their rents on time
making sure that the self-employed also
get the mortgages they need
this government has made sure that there
is a healthy supply of 95
mortgages tens of thousands of
first-time buyers have since bought
their home thanks to our mortgage
guarantee scheme
we'd like to go further so today
i can announce a comprehensive review of
the mortgage market reporting back this
autumn it will look at how we can give
our nation of aspiring homeowners better
access to low deposit mortgages and what
our own mortgage industry can learn from
counterparts around the world who have
alternative ways of offering finance
managing risk and unbolting the door to
ownership
and just
as no
generation should be locked out of home
home ownership because of where they
were born so nobody should be barred
from that same dream simply because of
where they live now for four decades it
has been possible for council home
tenants to use a discount to buy the
property they live in
over that time almost two million people
have been helped into home ownership
they've switched identities and
psychology from being dependent on the
state for every repair from damp
proofing to a new front door to being in
charge of their own family home able to
make improvements and add value as they
please
for various reasons the number of
tenants who actually use this freedom
has been steadily diminishing
so now is the moment to widen the
possibilities and to give greater
freedoms to those who yearn to buy
i want us to deliver on the
long-standing commitment made by several
governments to extend the right to buy
to housing associations
there are still 1.6 million people 1.6
million households living in council
homes but there are now 2.5 million
households whose homes belong to housing
associations and they're trapped they
can't buy they don't have the security
of ownership they can't treat their home
as their own or make the improvements
that they want
and
while some housing associations are
excellent others have been known to
treat their tenants with scandalous
indifference
so it's time
for change
over the coming months we will work with
the sector to bring forward a new right
to buy scheme it will work for tenants
giving millions more the chance to own
their own home it will work for
taxpayers responsibly capped at a level
that is fully paid for affordable within
our existing spending plans and with one
for one replacement of each social
housing property sold
and
even as we deliver this home ownership
revolution we will continue with a
revolution in renters rights as the
fifth anniversary of the grenfell
tragedy approaches we need no reminders
of the importance of landlords listening
to and working with their tenants which
is why we're giving tenants across the
social and private sector better homes
greater security and access to the kind
of justice which we all deserve about
which many are currently denied
we're also dealing with a scourge of
unfair leasehold terms often every bit
as onerous as the conditions imposed
upon tenants by landlords but applied to
those who as home owners should have far
greater control over their homes and
their lives
in this parliament we will supercharge
leaseholders ability
to buy their own freehold
helping 4.6 million households
genuinely to own their own home
with discounts of up to 90 for those
trapped with egregious escalating ground
rents
we will finish the right to own reforms
margaret thatcher began in the 1980s
ending the absurd position where
first-time buyers spend their life
savings on flats only to find themselves
being charged hundreds of pounds for
painting their own doors or even unable
to own a dog
that's what being on your side
is all about
when ownership remains beyond the reach
of a great many hard-working people it's
neither right nor fair
to put ever faster sums
of taxpayers money
straight into the pocket
of landlords
the total bill for housing support
stands at about 30 billion pounds a year
and the office for budget responsibility
has warned that if we don't take action
it could reach 50 billion pounds by
2050.
that is cash taxpayers cash that is
being simply swallowed to pay the
mortgages of private sector landlords or
being swallowed by housing associations
it's time to put this huge wall of money
taxpayers money to better use
it's time to turn benefits to bricks
so we're going to look to change the
rules on welfare so that the 1.5 million
working people who are in receipt of
housing benefits and want what i stress
working people
and who want to buy their first home
will be given
a new choice to spend their benefit on
rent as now or put it towards a first
ever mortgage
doing so removes a significant barrier
that currently prevents hundreds of
thousands of families from buying their
own home
and to remove another we're going to
explore discounting lifetime and help to
buy isis savings from universal credit
eligible eligibility rules
that doesn't mean letting anyone who
claims benefits uh while sitting a a
on a vast pension pot that they could be
drawing on that that that's not the
people we're targeting but making it
easier
for hard-working people to put away a
little every month until they have
enough for a deposit on their first home
to help keep people in a home if they're
unfortunate enough to become unemployed
we're going to let people access support
for paying their mortgage that much
earlier than is presently the case
and last of all we're going to look at
how we can securitize some of that
colossal 30 billion pound housing
benefits bill
so we can build more social homes with
the potential
of a right to buy
you add all those up all those measures
together
i think it will not only help us to
build many more homes in the right place
but will help millions of people realize
what is currently an unattainable dream
of home ownership
and that will be of massive benefit
massive so massive benefit to them
massive social benefit to this country
and of course massive economic benefit
to this country uh not just in the way
that it drives jobs and growth in the
housing market of course in the
construction industry but also in the
way that it helps to address the
the productivity problems uh that have
beset the uk for so long
we are on your side
in
cutting the costs of
childcare we're on your side in cutting
the costs of
fuel
we're on your side and cutting transport
costs and we're on your side in cutting
the cost of home ownership
and of course we are on your side in
cutting the tax bill as fast as you
responsibly can and that in itself
is an immense driver of productivity and
growth
and
in spite of all the pressures that this
economy currently faces
we know that we will get through them as
we got through previous uh pressures and
emerge stronger the other side because
that is our plan for a stronger economy
by tackling the costs of living in all
the ways that i have set out and more
by keeping
energy housing transport
tackle the those costs with supply side
reforms in all the ways i've i've set
out keeping our borrowing and debt under
control giving us uh the scope both to
cut taxes on people on families and of
course on business
and then backing business to grow and
invest in this country in the way that
uh they are colossal sums coming into
the uk right now as you as everybody
knows the we are the easily the biggest
destination for tech investment anywhere
in uh in europe uh i think as much as
germany france and israel
combined
and
by continuing to secure and drive the
benefits of brexit our new freedoms
across the whole of the uk
everything from free ports to financial
services
we will continue to make sure the people
of this country achieve
and continue to achieve the happiness
and
security
that comes from having
a high wage high skilled job
in ever greater numbers that's what
we're achieving right now and that's
what we're going to get continue to
achieve and that is how that is how it's
it's that plan for a a stronger economy
uh that will mean uh that we will be
able to get on with the mission on which
this government was uh elected to unite
and level up across our country
so that no matter where you are born or
what your background we will give you
the chance to fulfill your potential
with a plan i think for a stronger
economy and that has
all the makings to be the strongest and
most prosperous in europe thank you all
very much for listening and thank you
blackpool and the filed college for your
warm welcome this morning thank you
thank you all very much right now we're
gonna go straight away we're gonna go we
we've got
six questions from the media uh and um
i'm gonna go straight away to the bbc
chris mason
[Applause]
thank you chris mason from bbc news and
many people prime minister are
desperately worried about the cost of
living and yet they see in you a prime
minister described by a former
conservative leader no less as someone
driving down the motorway with two flat
tires
why should people believe you when you
say you can deliver when 40 of your mps
don't think you can
right chris you know there i was uh
really hoping that you would uh talk
about all the things that we're doing to
uh to to take the country forward uh but
never mind uh i i venerate i venerate
the organization uh from which you come
and i and i will i think the the answer
the answer is very simple uh if you if
you if you want a proof point of of what
we're going to uh deliver look at what
we've already uh delivered uh look at
the uh the way we got the country
through the the worst pandemic i think
for for a hundred years uh the the speed
and efficiency of the uh of the vaccine
rollout and uh look at look at the fact
that we've emerged from it when people
were saying uh that we would have
unemployment in the region of 12 to 14
uh with the lowest rate of unemployment
uh since uh since 1974 uh youth
unemployment at or near record lows uh
what i'm saying to you today and i'm
speaking very frankly to uh to the
country is i believe we now have a uh a
problem uh that follows on directly from
kovid i think it's less severe uh than
the
the the challenge of that pandemic but
it's important to level with people
about the the price uh pressures that
that uh that we face and to explain uh
what the government is doing and i think
that the measures that we're setting out
uh in in tackling uh the cost of living
not just by using taxpayers money but by
reforming uh services uh by reforming
the way government uh operates cutting
costs of government uh but also making
sure that we we change uh
everything from uh our energy markets to
uh our mass transportation uh systems
and as i uh said it's quite some length
uh just now an opportunity to help
people with their single biggest cost uh
which is housing and uh that is if you
look at family budgets that's where the
money goes and people find ownership uh
something really really very difficult
to attain and that's the uh and i think
that's wrong i think that people we
what you have
in this package today is some very
creative ideas not just to build more
homes in the right places and that's
crucial you've got to build more you've
got to build more uh but you've also got
to give people the the chance uh to to
to live in them to own them uh
whatever tenure and by the way you ask
about delivery
never forget and if anybody asks about
social housing uh you know i've built
more social housing than the labour
mayor uh pastor the previous one and the
current one uh so so we get on uh and
build but what we want to do is give
people the chance of ownership and i
think it's a massive massive thing to do
it's a massive magic thing to do and
it's
it's
it's it's right it's right for people
and it's right for families and i think
it's right for uh the economy as well uh
dan hewitt of of itv
uh thank you very much for
watching isn't the really big problem
here
in this country this simply we simply
don't have enough affordable homes you
made no mention in your speech of the
121 000 children currently living in
temporary accommodation or the 1 million
plus families on social housing waiting
lists far from building more homes for
them doesn't this policy of right to buy
seriously risk selling off what few
affordable homes we have left in this
country
and you said you want to build more
social homes what do you commit to
providing a number of social homes you
want to see built year on year yeah so
i'm going to totally reject your uh
we we build huge numbers of affordable
homes uh right now and we can be very
proud when i was as i said just now to
to chris uh when i was right i built
more than a hundred thousand affordable
homes in uh in london in my time as
mayor uh far more i think from memory
than uh ken lemison did and certainly i
built them at a far greater rate uh than
the current mayor uh did we build
affordable homes as far as i can
remember we built more affordable homes
in one year of the incoming uh
conservative government uh after 2010
then uh or coalition government than the
labour party did in 13 years uh in
office so uh we understand the vital
importance of of of council homes and
affordable homes actually the
interesting thing about this country is
that we do have by comparison with many
other european countries a lot of social
housing uh one in five homes in this
country is is social housing and that's
far more than france germany or most
other most other countries and what we
want to do is make sure that we give
people the chance not just to live in an
affordable home but eventually uh when
they want to
when they feel that their situation
enables them to to buy it
and that's a fantastic mobilizing
motivating thing that drives uh
people's thoughts and passions and
engages them deeply and they and it's a
it's a very very important change to
make if you can but of course we will
continue to insist as i said in the in
the speech there's a one-to-one
replacement uh so that when the the
sales are made that you use the receipts
uh to build more and of course uh it
costs less to uh to build than to than
to buy and uh so that's the way we'll do
it
well we want to see we want to see at
least a a replacement and we want we
want to we want i mean we want to build
hundreds of thousands uh more homes
every year and i think i think i think
i'm right in saying that in the in the
um
year before kovid
the number of homes built in this
country uh under this government was
about two i think 245 000 uh which is
almost a 30-year high
we are
you you you look as you look as though
you don't believe me
well
as i said as i said as i said to you as
i as i said to you we are building we
are building consistently more
affordable homes uh than labor uh ever
did and uh when you when you look at the
council house uh numbers uh we leave
them absolutely we left them absolutely
standing of course we want uh more uh
affordable homes but the way to do that
is to have more home building uh full
stop and you won't get and i know very
well that you won't get you every any
development uh has got to have a mixture
of
of market sale and affordable and the
the problem that we've had is that uh
successive labor uh governments have
imposed such ridiculous quotas on
developments that nothing has gone ahead
and so you haven't actually seen
development at all you've seen no
private sector building or affordable
either and what we want to do
is get the market going in places where
it works on brownfield sites that are
made viable by the infrastructure
investments that were were putting in
that i barely began to uh to describe
and that is the way that's how we always
outbuild uh the the
labour party when it comes to delivering
social homes as well as as private homes
and that is what we're going to continue
to do gb news darren mccaffrey
thank you prime minister um just on on
the supply of homes you're right i think
it was about 245 000 in 2019 but you're
committed to 300 000 homes
by the middle of this decade in fact 300
000 is what expert says is standing
still no conservative government has
done it over the last 12 years can you
give a cast iron guarantee that by the
middle of this decade you would at least
reach that manifesto commitment and
doesn't that frankly mean
changing planning laws dealing with
nimbyism and just second of all
indeed and just second of all on on fuel
because today
i think a new record's been broken that
is going to cost the average family 100
quids
to top up their cars
now you've caught taxes in this country
fuel duty by 5p i've done some research
on the train on the way up here prime
minister in ireland it's 17p this is in
recent months spain 17p
france 13 pence the netherlands 14 p
cuts
uh germany 25 pence i could go on 5p
isn't enough is it prime minister we're
the second highest fuel duty tax country
in europe you're gonna have to go
further than five pounds aren't you
so
down first of all on uh our ambition for
for home home building i'd you know i
think it was
back in you have to go right right back
to 1968 uh to find a time when we were
building more than four hundred thousand
uh homes a year in in this country so it
you know that we we've we've never built
enough fast enough because of all the
the reasons that you you rightly
describe um but
everybody understands that this is a we
are sensitive to development that isn't
in the right place and that's perfectly
reasonable we love our natural uh world
we want we want to make sure that you
have development that is that is
appropriate but that's why i think the
reforms that michael gove is putting
through uh today the second reading of
the leveling up and regeneration bill
are right and they will give local
people uh much more control over water
uh to to cite things to allow uh
appropriate developments to go ahead in
places where they will be welcome to
where they will help
young uh people growing up in those
communities and that i think that is
what people want around this country i
think it will allow uh development uh to
go ahead
in ways that we haven't seen before i
can't give you uh a cast iron guarantee
that uh we're going to get uh
a number in a particular year but what i
can point you to is the record of of
delivery under conservative governments
and the way that we do it and you know
clearly uh you've got to make sure that
you're not building uh everywhere on uh
on you know precious uh green belt land
uh that you're you're taking care of the
uh of the natural world
but there you don't have to the the
trick to pull off to build uh more homes
is
as i as i was saying to uh i think maybe
it's to chris you you've got to you've
got to put in the infrastructure you've
got to make sure that not in not only
the
the schools and hospitals but the the
roads the mass transit system the the
transport systems uh to enable those
developments to be viable the problem is
if you take a
development like barking riverside which
i have to know quite well uh or
all the stuff up in the thames gateway
area and you know well we're killing
we're a long way out from from blackpool
when we discuss this but uh i i remember
these developments intimately because i
tried to do
it's when you don't have the
uh the transport uh that they're not
viable for the developers and when
they're not viable for the developers
you can't get the affordable either
but if you put in the
crossrail
for instance uh will enable us to do
things that were simply not possible and
uh they will it will cross well would
enable developments to go ahead in parts
of our capital
uh that were not economically viable and
that's one of the reasons so you'll be
able to give people access to the
housing uh that they need and that that
is what this government is doing that's
why
we've got a huge program of
infrastructure 650 billion pounds worth
of uh investment overall in uh
infrastructure skills and technology
look at what we're doing that is
designed uh partly to to enable the
private sector to come in and build
homes where people want them where they
won't be on the green belt and where
they can
they can
do the job for uh for a generation to
come on
fuel
i i i hear you we we made a we made a
cut already uh what i want to see uh the
biggest cut ever in in fuel duty uh i i
what i want to see is
those cuts in taxation not just
swallowed up in one gulp without
touching the gullet uh of the uh of the
the fuel companies i want to see i want
to see those
those those cuts having an impact on the
pumps and uh we are we are watching very
closely to uh to see what happens as i
said i think many companies
don't want to
just take profit they do have a sense of
responsibility
but uh but we need to see it
i i when i when it comes to fiscal
measures uh darren as you as you can as
you can really imagine this is the
province of my uh my right honourable
friend the chancellor i'm not going to
anticipate what he may or may not do but
i can tell you uh that we are going to
continue to do everything in our power
to look after the uh the british people
throughout uh this pandemic and and as
throughout the aftershocks of the of the
pandemic just as we did uh during covet
and and i've said that many many times i
think uh people know that to be uh that
that to be right
geraldine scott of the times
thank you prime minister um you've
spoken a lot today about low deposits um
but arguably the more difficult factor
for a lot of people that want to go on
the ladder is that multiply you said
yourself it's up to nine times now so
what can you do to tackle that because
even if you scrape the deposit together
that's a massive barrier and are you
looking at mortgage insurance like they
have in canada to secure those load
deposits and then just the second one on
tax you've got your big speech with the
chancellor coming up in the next couple
of weeks um we understand at the times
you're looking to cut income tax to two
pence but in 2024 rather than one pence
buy two pence
driving you're driving a hard bargain
i
[Laughter]
buy two pens rather than one pence uh in
2024 is that something you're looking at
okay well look uh so jeremy first of all
thank you on on uh the
um
the mortgage market uh the what what we
want to i
i yes people should we we've got about
we'll help people to get deposits uh but
we also need to have um
mortgages that you know we need to have
many more 95 more 95 mortgages so
mortgages that uh uh
cover 95 of cost of the
of the property um it is punitively
difficult for uh so many people now in
this country uh it doesn't need to be
that way that's one of the reasons where
uh we're reforming it um and there are
products already there
but they sort of come and they go we
want to make sure there's a ready stream
of of such products for uh for the
people who need them as well as all the
other um initiatives that i mentioned
just now on
uh what rishi and i are talking about on
on on fiscal measures i'm sorry to say
that you are just going to have to
contain your uh your impatience there i
mean i think reducing income tax to 2p
uh is you know is is
nobody not not
not not even on the on the back benches
of the tory party nobody has yet
proposed that to me uh but
we are we are we
i know and i think everybody in this
country knows that because of kovid uh
we had a massive fiscal shock
and it was because of the strength of
our economy that we were able to look
after people
and and we still are
we just want to make sure that as we
come out of it uh we keep things strong
uh takes uh sensible steps but uh of
course uh we are we as i think i said at
least a couple of times uh we're
strongly inclined to stimulate further
growth further productivity uh with tax
cuts as and when uh they become uh
sensible uh mason boycott owner of the
telegraph
uh thank you prime minister um
you say that you want to get the tax
burden down for working people
um
and you say that you want to cut taxes
when that's responsible is it not
responsible now to do that to help with
cost of living and
to help drive growth
thanks well that's why
we for instance are cutting uh taxes
cutting national insurance contributions
already uh 70 of the people who pay nics
are getting a tax cut next month
worth an average of 330 pounds
as i said earlier on where uh we're
cutting council tax for most people by
150 pounds we cut fuel duty by the
biggest amount
ever but yes of course uh we're going to
continue to look at ways in which uh we
can we can sensibly reduce
the burden uh and help uh help
households in any way that we can
cost of housing is a is a big chunk of
expenditure transport's a big chunk
child child care has been energy is an
ever-growing chunk uh but tax is the
biggest of all
and uh we certainly aim to get that down
uh jessel got of the guardian
thank you prime minister
um two questions if i may um the oecd um
predicts us having the lowest growth in
the g20 apart from russia i think we can
diagnose russia's problem um
but what you you talked a lot in the
beginning of your speech about the
international issues that are that are
causing slow economic growth but why is
it a particular what is britain
particularly doing wrong to have the
lowest to have that such low growth and
a quick second one if i may just just to
follow up on the petrol question and you
say that you're watching retailers very
closely and say but but what what if
they do if they continue to not pass on
the cuts what will the government do
well that's okay so first of all on the
on the the current the trends in uh in
growth numbers don't forget because we
came out first because of the steps that
we took uh we were slightly out of sync
with uh much of the rest of the uh of
the oecd we we were we we had a faster
recovery because we can't we had a fast
fashion right like we came out we came
out of it fast we're particularly
exposed now uh to to energy uh price
shock
uh that's because i'm afraid the uk is
just not self-reliant enough uh we made
a big dash for gas if you remember the
price of gas has gone up we totally
failed to invest in a nuclear that left
us without the the self-reliance that we
need on uh on energy prices
as i say we're trying to this government
is now urgently trying to rectify that
we're stampeding towards uh more uh more
offshore wind uh
more
more
uh more nuclear uh
the trouble is that they will come on uh
oshawa wind in particular can come on
stream uh quickly but it it it requires
uh it will take it will take some time
but if you if you look at the the
nuclear will certainly take some time uh
but
i i think that the
there will be an abatement as i say of
those uh those costs uh within the the
foreseeable future i can you know you
can see uh
the prospect of inflation coming down
again
and i just remind you that when you look
at the uh the imf uh forecasts or or
other forecasts uh they actually have
the uk uh returning at or to at or near
uh the top of the of the g7 growth
league uh not to in the not too distant
uh future jess so be of uh be a good
cheer uh about that and uh but my the
purpose of my speech today is just to
say to everybody look
yes
price pressures are going to make things
tough for a while but we will get
through it here are the steps that we're
taking
to get through it and at the other side
we will have a much much stronger
economy and
on your second question which was i
think about
fuel prices
watching the pumps uh we are watching it
um and of course we hope that
corporations will
be responsible and will
recognize that now is the time not just
to take price
uh but to to look after consumers and
that's in that that's in their long-term
interests as well and uh well you know
as i think i said to um
possibly darren uh that you know i'm not
going to anticipate what the uh fiscal
decisions the chancellor uh may take but
we will continue uh to look after people
in any way that we can thank you all
very much for your time this morning i
much much appreciate this afternoon
thank you thank you
that was the prime minister speaking in
blackpool of first big sort of speech
and policy announcement of course after
his vote of confidence that he won
successfully uh earlier in the week
there was a question or two on that
which he uh dutifully dodged as as
expected and tried to push people back
to the topic of conversation which was
both a broad outline on spending and
taxation with a particular focus as well
on housing uh let's uh just run through
some of the headlines uh from uh that
speech he said uh it really struck a
tone of a fiscal conservative for not
the first time but uh perhaps in the
most significant way after of course his
government uh has been uh
one that has spent a lot particularly
through the pandemic he said more
spending is not the answer time for the
government
to stop spending he suggested if
stimulation of the economy was needed is
better to come by cutting taxes uh then
more spending uh he said quote
time for the government to get out of
the way he did go through the
possibility with the inflation that
we've got at the moment of a wage
price spiral and a need to get inflation
under control more risks more spending
risks fanning the flames of inflation
he said as well as damaging public
finances for the long term having of
course already spent so much uh in
recent years through the pandemic
he did then of course move more
specifically
onto housing and the housing
revolution he said a promise to build
more houses he didn't make a cast iron
guarantee of 300 000 houses per year by
the middle uh of this decade though and
he also spoke about the need to make it
easier for people to get mortgages with
small deposits he outlined that now the
typical uh
cost of a house relative to people's
incomes is about nine-fold a sharp rise
in recent decades to get to that point
spoke about people needing to be able to
get a 98 mortgage i only have to put
down a two percent uh deposit to get a
house and that there would be a review
of how mortgages are issued that might
of course end up putting a lot of
pressure on banks and mortgage companies
to take a hell of a lot more risk if
they're only going to accept a two
percent deposit we need more details
on that uh he did say
uh that he didn't in fact rule out if we
move back to some of the tax and spend
points didn't rule out cutting fuel duty
further he was asked about that seemed
to suggest spreading out those sorts of
cuts
made more sense so that quote they're
not gun gone in one gulp but he was also
not drawn on whether a bigger future cut
of income tax
should come or will come and he also did
criticize unions uh of course in the
transport sector that are due to go on
strike soon um we might have a clip of
the speech uh to to review as well i'm
not sure if we do or not uh i'll have
that a bit later on in fact uh and and
we'll also hear from sam coats who's in
the room there in blackpool with the
prime minister and we will review all of
that again in full uh when sam is ready
now in another blow to household
finances the average cost of filling up
a car with petrol has topped 100 pounds
for the first time with the rac
describing it as a truly dark day for
drivers the average price of unleaded
petrol is now
182.3 pence per liter that's up 1.6
pence from yesterday diesel also up and
now averages
188.1 pence per liter that's up one and
a half pence since yesterday you can see
here how the cost of petrol and diesel
has